hi guys this is a drought from simply
learn and today we'll be talking about
10 certifications that will help you
grow in your career in the year 2019 at
number 10 we have digital marketing
first let's go through some of the
options that you have
there are certifications by Google
Facebook HubSpot HootSuite and simply
learn so from Google you have the Google
Ads fundamental certification the
Facebook Certified planning professional
certification hub sports content
marketing certification a huge suite
social marketing certification and
simply learns digital marketing
specialists master's program now there
are a few prerequisites before you can
start any of these certifications
firstly you need to know the best
practices when it comes to online
advertising or you can manage and
optimize ad campaigns on social media
like Facebook and Google understanding
how brand awareness ad performance and
campaign optimization works and how
online advertising can help you meet
your clients quotes now some of the job
profiles that are open to you our
digital marketing analyst SEO
specialists SEM manager digital
marketing manager and other fields that
you could get into our content marketing
email marketing social media marketing
and so on now let's talk about how much
they cost and the average salary that
you get now the examination fees can go
up to thousand four hundred ninety nine
dollars however you do get certain
certifications for free like the Google
Ads fundamentals and the hub spots
content marketing now the average salary
goes up to eighty seven thousand dollars
per annum
but this does increase significantly as
your years of experience increase now
some of the companies that require such
certifications are Amazon Warner Bros
Colgate coca-cola and so on now let's go
to number nine networking now some of
the more prominent certifications that
you can find with networking are the
cisco certified network associate which
is a associate or Bignell level
certification which has various fields
like the CCNA cloud collaboration cyber
ops datacenter industrial and so on then
you have the cisco certified network
professional which is the professional
level certification with an advanced
level of knowledge which shows more
expertise with networking skills then
you have the cisco certified internet
work expert and the Wireshark certified
network
analysts now you do have prerequisites
in this case as well because you need to
know of the system and cloud networks
work or they're installed of the work
and how they can be maintained you need
to be able to design system
configuration to direct system
installation and to ensure that certain
system standards are met you need to
ensure that the integrity of the network
infrastructure is able to provide
maximum performance you need to also
understand how you can perform disaster
recovery and protect data software and
hardware from malicious attacks now some
of the job profiles that are open to you
are that of a network specialist network
engineer a network administrator and
network architect the exam fees in this
case ranges from $299 $2,400 the average
salary is about one hundred and twelve
thousand dollars per annum now some of
the companies that require the
certification are IBM Microsoft Cisco
AWS and so on and next up we have number
eight business intelligence now some of
these certifications that are offered to
you are the tableau desktop specialists
and the tableau server qualified
associate the Microsoft certification of
analyzing and visualizing data with
Microsoft power bi click view business
analyst and the SAS certified BI content
developer now apart from this simple ion
also provides certifications in each of
these technologies some of the
prerequisites before you can take these
certifications are to have a good
understanding of business intelligence
tools such as tableau power bi QlikView
and SAS you need to know about the ETL
also known as extract transform and load
in data you need to know about the
fundamentals of database and query
languages like SQL and you need to have
expertise when it comes to visualization
now some of the job profiles that you
have access to are that of a tableau
developer a power bi developer click
view developer and business intelligence
analyst the examination fees in this
case ranges from one hundred and twenty
five dollars to two hundred and fifty
dollars the average salary of someone
certified with these certifications is
about 117 thousand US dollars per annum
now some of the companies that use these
certifications are IBM Microsoft
Deloitte BMW and so on
and now we are at number seven
project management now let's have a look
at some of the certifications firstly we
have the project management professional
and the certified associate in project
management certification provided by the
project management institute now let's
talk about PMP or the project management
professional certification now for this
you need to complete 35 hours of project
management education and the certificate
is valid for three years and after three
years if you want to hold on to that
certificate you have to have acquired
sixty PDUs our professional development
units during the three-year cycle now
let's talk about CAPM or the certified
associate in project management
certification now to hold on to that
certification you need to retake the
exam every five years next you have the
prince2 foundation and practitioner
certification which have a very high 55%
Pathmark for both the foundation and
practitioner examinations then you have
the certified scrum master certification
and the agile scrum master certification
now here are the prerequisites when it
comes to these certifications you need
to understand the strategic and
operational areas in project management
you need to have domain knowledge when
it comes to leading-edge technologies
you need to be perfect when it comes to
all the aspects of project management
for the entire life of the project and
experience in managing large-scale
cross-divisional projects and some of
the job profiles that are offered to you
or that of a project manager project
coordinator and scrum master now the
examination fees for these
certifications ranges from $295 to four
hundred five dollars the average salary
of someone certified is about one
hundred and six thousand US dollars per
annum now some of the companies that
require these certifications are dell
vmware Boyne HP ASAP and so on and here
we have number six cyber security now
let's have a look at some of the
certifications offered firstly we have
the certified information systems
security professional certification this
is provided by IC square now they also
provide other certifications like SSCP
ccs pcap and CSS LP under a wide range
of accredited security certifications
now the ISACA provides two
certifications when it comes to
cybersecurity like the certified
information security manager
certification and the certified interest
information systems control
certification now the CIA SM or the
certified information security manager
is intended for those people who have
the knowledge and experience required to
develop and manage an enterprise
information security system the seer is
called the certified in risk and
information systems control
certification is an advanced
certification in risk management finally
we have the certified ethical hacker
certification now this is one of these
certifications that helps reinforce the
fact that ethical hacking is a unique
and self-regulating profession now here
are the prerequisites when it comes to
these certifications you need to be
well-versed in programming languages
like dotnet Java Python C sharp as well
as other web services like rest and soap
understanding of cloud platforms like
AWS as your google cloud and so on you
need to have experience in configuring
and working with security tools such as
firewalls antivirus softwares patch
management systems and so on you also
need to know about virtualization and
operating systems like Windows and Linux
the job profiles that are open to you
are that of a security administrator a
cyber security engineer the cyber
security Solutions Architect and cyber
security analyst now the examination
fees for these certifications range from
four hundred fifteen dollars to nine
hundred and fifty dollars the average
salary of someone certified with these
certifications is 131 thousand dollars
per annum and some of the companies that
use these certifications are HP moody
way Pro Boeing and so on now we are at
number five CRM or customer relationship
management now let's have a look at some
of these certifications firstly you have
three certifications provided by
Salesforce which are the Salesforce
administrator Salesforce platform
developer and Salesforce platform app
builder now Salesforce provides two
certifications in CRM one is that of an
administrator and the other which is
that of a developer then you have the
ASAP CRM certification which is provided
by the company SAP now this is the kind
of certification where it's recommended
that you combine educational courses and
hands-on experience to help you prepare
for your certification exam then you
have the Microsoft Dynamics CRM and
simply learn Salesforce certification
training now this is designed to ensure
that you learn and master the concepts
of being a Salesforce administrator and
Salesforce
from app builder now some of the
prerequisites for these certifications
are a strong knowledge of front-end
technologies like HTML and JavaScript
you need to be clear with at least one
programming language like Java C sharp
or net you need to know the fundamentals
of database and less TPI's and about how
customer relationship management tools
work now some of the job profiles are
open to you our CRM manager CRM
strategists Salesforce administrator and
CRM developer now the exam fees for
these certifications range from $250 two
thousand four hundred and ninety nine
dollars the average salary for someone
certified with these certifications are
one hundred and thirty-five thousand
dollars per annum and some of the
companies that use the certifications
are Facebook Google Microsoft Wells
Fargo and so on now we are at number
four big data now let's have a look at
some of these certifications firstly we
have the cloud our certifications you
have the CCS Park and Hadoop developer
the CCA administrator and the CCA data
analysts certifications now cloud ora
has many certifications when it comes to
big data and what we mentioned here are
the most popular ones after you're done
with the CCA certifications or the cloud
era certified associate certifications
you can go for the CCP or the cloud era
certified professional certifications
next we have certifications from
Hortonworks which are the HDP certified
developer big data hadoop the HTTP
apache spark developer and Hortonworks
certified Associates certification
now these certifications require you to
master the Hortonworks hadoop
distribution and test your practical
knowledge Big Data Hadoop and spark then
we have the simple and certifications of
Big Data Hadoop and spark developer Big
Data and Hadoop administrator and big
data architect master's program now
let's talk about some of the
prerequisites before you can take the
certification firstly you need in-depth
experience in developing data
engineering solutions on Hadoop and
other related platforms you need to know
the fundamentals and have an
understanding of traditional Hadoop
systems cloud era CD edge and hot and
works data platform you need to have
working knowledge of Hadoop HDFS yann
MapReduce scoop hive and Impala along
with Apache spark and related
technologies
ETL an SQL knowledge will definitely
to your advantage and some of the job
profiles are open to you are that of a
Big Data Solutions Architect a big data
administrator a big data developer and a
big data analyst of the examination fee
for these certifications range from $100
two thousand two hundred and ninety-nine
dollars the average salary when it comes
to someone certified with these
certifications are about one hundred and
thirty seven thousand dollars per annum
some of the companies that use these
certifications are Nvidia GoDaddy PayPal
HP and so on at number three we have
DevOps now let's talk about some DevOps
certifications simply learn provides
three certifications one of them being
the DevOps architect which is a master's
program DevOps certification and the
chef puppet ansible and selenium
certifications now these certification
courses will help you become an expert
in all the tools and technologies that
are used in the DevOps approach you'll
become an expert in the principles of
continuous development and deployment
automation of configuration management
Inter team collaboration and IT service
ability you'll be using modern DevOps
tools like git docker Jenkins and simple
nagi O's cucumber and so on you also
have an AW certification the aw
certified DevOps Engineer now you need
to be good with the concepts of both AWS
and DevOps to get the certification now
some of the prerequisites for these
certifications are that you need to know
how the DevOps lifecycle is and DevOps
tools you need to know about programming
languages about the fundamentals of
building coding testing integrating and
maintaining a software project and
experience in working with DevOps tools
on cloud platforms some of the job
profiles that are open to you are data
for DevOps architect a DevOps engineer a
DevOps manager and a DevOps systems
administrator the examination fees for
these certifications range from hundred
fifty dollars to seven hundred and
ninety nine dollars the average salary
of someone certified these
certifications are about one hundred and
forty three thousand dollars per annum
some of the companies that use these
certifications are IDM Lenovo Cisco
Netflix and so on and now we're at
number two which is cloud computing now
before we get into the certifications
you guys should know that cloud
computing is a booming industry that
provides a large amount of high-paying
jobs for those
people who have the right technical
skills to create solutions on the cloud
now each of the famous cloud vendors
have their own certification the most
popular ones are the AWS solutions
architect certification the Microsoft
Azure solutions architects certification
the Google professional cloud architects
certification and we also have a
certification from IC square which is
the certified cloud security
professional certification some of the
prerequisites for these certifications
are a good understanding of cloud
solutions which are provided by AWS
Microsoft Azure or Google cloud you need
to have at least a year of hands-on
experience and designing available
cost-efficient and fault-tolerant
systems on AWS Azure of Google Cloud you
need to have hands-on experience using
compute networking storage and database
services and hands-on experience when it
comes to deploying and maintaining cloud
solutions some of the job profiles that
are open to you are that of a cloud
architect cloud engineer cloud software
developer and the cloud system
administrator the examination fee for
these certifications range from one
hundred fifty dollars to five hundred
and forty nine dollars the average
salary for someone certified with these
certifications are about one hundred and
forty two thousand dollars per annum
some of the companies that use these
certifications are IBM Microsoft Google
VMware and so on and finally we are at
number one data science and machine
learning now when it comes to this
category you can opt for simply on
certifications and data science simply
learn provide certifications like data
science with Python data science with
our data science with SAS and a data
scientist master's program we have
course advisers who are influences in
the world of data science and machine
learning the master's program helps you
master skills and tools like statistics
hypotheses testing clustering decision
trees our studio data visualization and
so much more some of the prerequisites
when it comes to data science
certifications you need to be able to
design develop and execute solutions to
solve business problems you need to have
a great level of expertise when it comes
to mathematical models numerical
analysis and statistics and need to have
working knowledge of at least one
programming language you also need to
have the ability to wrangle data which
is to clean many plate and organize the
data you also need to know how you can
visualize these results and you
need to know the fundamentals of machine
learning algorithms and how you can
implement them some of the job profiles
that are open to you are that of a data
scientist data analyst data engineer and
data architect the examination fee for
these certifications ranged from five
hundred ninety nine dollars two thousand
two hundred ninety nine dollars the
average salary of someone certified in
these certifications is one hundred and
forty thousand dollars per annum some of
the companies that use these
certifications are IBM Microsoft Google
Goldman Sachs JP Morgan and so on let's
have a look at the machine learning
certifications firstly we have the
machine learning with tensorflow
certification provided by the Google
cloud platform here you are
experimenting with end to end machine
learning starting from building a
machine learning focused strategy and
progressing into model training
optimization and production realization
with hands-on labs using the Google
cloud platform then we have the simple
on certifications which are the machine
learning certification deep learning
with tensorflow certification and the
artificial intelligence engineer which
is a master's program now with these
certifications you're able to master
machine learning concepts and techniques
including supervised and unsupervised
learning mathematical and heuristic
aspects hands-on modeling to develop
algorithms and and all sorts of
preparation for the role of a machine
learning engineer some of the
prerequisites before these
certifications are to create and
maintain machine learning solutions to
solve business problems having a good
degree of experience when it comes to
implementing machine learning algorithms
knowledge of any of the popular
programming languages like Python or in
Java and data engineering skills such as
experience in pre-processing ETL and
database management some of the job
profiles that were open to you at that
of a machine learning engineer machine
learning scientist deep learning
engineer and AI engineer the examination
fee for these certifications ranged from
$60 to $799 and the average salary for
someone certified with these
certifications is one hundred and forty
thousand dollars per animal
some of the companies that use these
certifications are Nvidia Adobe Boeing
Facebook and so on and with that we've
reached the end of this video I hope it
has inspired you to grow in your career
by learning and mastering something new
this upcoming year thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here